[Music]
today i'm very excited actually to
cancel a woman by the name of lindsey go
uh this i believe is one of the most
highly deserved cancellations we've done
in several weeks so of course they're
all highly deserved our friend lindsay
is a sports reporter and also the sports
director over at wtoc in georgia now to
be a sports reporter in georgia
you have to know and love college
football because your audience knows and
loves college football and part of
loving college football is loving the
atmosphere the experience
now it's not for everybody certainly the
game of football is fast and violent and
intense and
sometimes brutal the experience of
watching the game live in the stadium
especially at college stadium is loud
and rowdy and soaked in beer with people
screaming out of anger and out of joy
often switching between the two from
second to second
as a football fan myself this all sounds
like a tremendous amount of fun to me
but as i said it's not for everybody and
i'm afraid it's not for lindsay so on
saturday night um georgia defeated
clemson at home in a hard-fought 10-3
victory
lindsay was reporting at the stadium
and decided to set up for a live shot
right at the exits as 90 000 drunk and
deliriously excited football fans were
filing out she chose to set up her
cameras
in the midst of this swarm
and then was less than pleased with the
results later that night she tweeted
got all kinds of violated during my
first live hit by fans
she also claimed that she'd been groped
quote unquote
and she said after that that the
experience was uh that she was stressed
by the experience and startled and quote
frazzled but courageously she assured
the public that she was okay
then the next day as the nation waited
with baited breath for an update from
lindsay who was stressed and frazzled at
the football game
she finally released the footage
now it's up to the eye of the beholder
or the beer holder as the case may be to
decide
whether lindsay was in fact groped and
violated or whether she was simply
greeted with the kind of boozy
enthusiasm that literally anyone
standing in front of a camera in that
situation would have experienced and
that's up to you to decide
but uh let's watch the footage here
hello
clt
we're hitting defensive slugfest and the
dogs ran away with it attend a furry win
how long how long do i have
please don't touch my equipment please
go
how long do i have i've got to move
okay um i can hear you but i'm moving
okay my only problem watching that is
all the people who
uh you know they got their time in the
sun they got their time on camera and
then they kind of froze and they had
nothing to say i mean if you're gonna if
you're gonna intrude into the shot
i respect it because again we're at a
football game that's what you do
but you should have something to say a
couple of people they they kind of stuck
their head into the shot and like didn't
they couldn't think of anything to say
so they just walked away
um now as far as i could tell only one
person made physical contact with her by
touching her on the shoulder
and as i always tell i tell my kids all
the time you got to keep your hands to
yourself it is impolite to touch
somebody on the shoulder like that when
they don't want to be touched
but um does that qualify as groping now
has a person been violated because
another person made non-consensual
contact with their shoulder for 10
seconds or two seconds really
if so then we have all been groped
we have all been groped and violated
thousands of times in our lives
and meanwhile the the stories of women
who have actually been groped and
violated are buried somewhere under this
avalanche of brief benign non-sexual
incidental physical contact between
human beings
as for the rest of it lindsay was
encountering what again anybody
who has set up any kind of camera
outside of any college or professional
sporting event has encountered
the crazy thing is you can see in her
face
from the beginning
that she has no patience for any noise
at all
she doesn't appear to want to be there
to begin with
and as soon as people start walking past
she's fuming mad
but but she's the one who set up the
camera exactly where thousands of people
will be walking this is like a guy from
the weather channel reporting live from
the beach during a hurricane and whining
the whole time because his hair is
getting wet
it's like if i tried to make a phone
call while sitting in the stands at a
nascar race like uh hang on a second hey
fellas can you pump the brakes for a
minute i'm trying to have a conversation
here
of course
that's that's not to say that reporters
can't or shouldn't report live from
stadiums it's just to say that they
should be ready to match the volume
intensity and exuberance of the crowd in
the background
and i certainly don't want to claim
that this is one of the reasons why men
make better sports reporters
i don't want to claim that
so i'm not going to claim that
instead instead i'll just show you an
example of how it's supposed to be done
watch this
well it's been 644 days since the last
time
did not have restrictions as to how many
fans could be in their stadium but that
ends tonight and while that ends a new
chapter begins as shane beamer begins
his new era as the head football coach
at the university of south carolina
hello everyone and welcome to
the front lots here at the university of
south carolina i'm mike cuba and it is
game day something gamecock fans have
been waiting for for quite some time and
look there's a lot of storylines we
could talk about we can talk about how
shane is making his debut we can talk
about how eric kimberly the former
gamecock quarterback who coached him
these last couple years is making his
debut as an assistant coach but perhaps
perhaps the biggest storyline
is the fact that you have a former grad
assistant coach seth norman
ryan under center tonight as the
starting quarterback earlier in the week
we had a chance to be able to catch up
with both seth and coach beaver
wow now that was fox reporter mike uva
who in fairness to lindsay mike is
putting on an absolute clinic in that
broadcast that few sports reporters
could fully match
uh and before you say that this was this
this was different because nobody
physically touched him
here he is broadcasting from a bar
during march madness a few years ago
here's a better example watch this
seconds seven seconds on five seconds
for the first time since 1973. usc has
run into the swift six days
wow
[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
people are a little bit excited you know
they're a little excited
covered in beer people grabbing onto his
back and his shoulders lindsay would be
in counseling for a year after that
experience that's what i i want to see
lindsay in that environment she would be
she would break down in tears
she'd be telling stories about the
trauma to her grandchildren 40 years
from now and who knows how the story
would evolve by then
now i was trying to do a live shot from
the bar and all these basketball fans
with machetes and chainsaws started
hacking me to pieces
maybe not literally but metaphorically
there are metaphorical chainsaws
now
it wouldn't be fair to say that all
female sports reporters are like lindsay
but even so
i must
say
this situation only demonstrates why i
personally prefer for sports broadcasts
especially football broadcasts to be
handled mostly by men
lindsay though worse than the average
even as far as female sports reporters
go
is definitely not the only female to
enter into this mostly male space and
seek to feminize it she wants the
football stadium to be quiet and gentle
considerate respectful of personal space
she wants it to be a more feminine
environment
she's not trying to assimilate herself
into the culture of football fans she is
rather hoping that they assimilate
themselves to her
this is a problem across our culture
sports just happen to be an area where
the problem is especially pronounced and
obvious females enter into areas that
have typically catered and mostly belong
to men
and and then
often quite successfully they try to to
change them to emasculate them and
thereby destroy the primary reason for
their existence in the first place
this phenomenon is so far reaching in
football especially that they're even
changing the rules now to make the game
itself more gentle and feminine football
is you know still violent
but it's less violent than it used to be
this year they're even focusing on
penalizing players who say mean or rude
things to each other on the football
field they've been doing this during the
preseason in the nfl
all of this
along with the token female sideline
reporters and the female analysts at
halftime
it's an effort to make the game less
appealing to the people the game was
invented for to begin with
now meanwhile should be acknowledged
women are experiencing the same problem
in the reverse
female spaces are being invaded by men
often the most private spaces like
locker rooms for example but but it's a
different kind of invasion
not better it's actually worse but it's
different
because
the men invading female spaces
do try to assimilate themselves but they
assimilate themselves too much
they assimilate themselves to the point
of pretending to actually be women and
the effect ultimately is that women
don't just lose their spaces
as men have lost ours they also lose
their identity in the process
so it's a big confused mess all in all
and it all starts from the incorrect
assumption that there is something wrong
with men and women having their own
spaces their own interests
their own identities
sports reporter lindsay didn't create
this problem but she is just one more
example of it and for that reason she is
today i must say
cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated